welcome to puppet mattress liquidators
how can I help you today I need to buy a
new bed
okay good good you came to the right
place I'd be more than happy to help Oh
Jett what size you need a full Queen
King Queen Queen oh we've got a big size
just so you know it needs to be sturdy
Oh
it's kind of crazy in my room well it's
a Posturepedic mattress we got right
here that's extremely comfortable and
durable do you mind if I try it no no go
ahead
I also mentioned there's a 100%
money-back guarantee on you got that
good no it's too hard do you have
anything softer um of course this is
just one of our armed natural latex
mattresses it's on sale too today at
$1,200 can I try it
sure
it seems a little pricey
okay no what's a little pricey I'll go
lie to you but no problem we got other
choices oh this is a great memory foam
mattress right here it's a little cheapo
and I try it out right right yeah of
course you want to try you know how it
goes hung up on them nice yeah yeah yeah
that's the one I'll take it okay let me
bring you
[Music]
you